[Music]
for the second year in a row we are
taking our show down to San Diego for
comic-con that's right we'll be will be
airing a week of shows live from the
Spreckels Theatre in San Diego remember
that last year it's a beautiful theater
- yeah we got a ton of exciting stuff
planned including interviews with the
cast of Silicon Valley the cast and
creators a game of Thrones and the cast
from the highly anticipated movie
Suicide Squad Plus yeah huge side squad
plus tons more surprise guest things
will be happening all week that'll be
fun I think it's all happening Wednesday
July 20th is a little different it's
gonna start on a Wednesday July 20th and
our shows will go through Sunday July
24th that's a little different for us
and just for Comic Con this is neat
we're bringing back conan 360 that's
right
Ronen 360 is an interactive experience
where you the viewer can watch our show
online use it what the hell I'm really
here oh you the viewer can watch our
show online using a variety of virtual
reality headsets including Google
cardboard this year we're bringing you
an even better 360 experience by having
not only one but four cameras in VR
recording ours now the high time you'll
feel like you're right inside the
theater with us you'll feel like you're
right inside us yeah you'll get the same
sense of dread that we have even more
exciting is that to help you get in on
the experience we're giving away free
Conan card boards that will let you
watch all of our VR content from San
Diego this is state-of-the-art cardboard
yes if you want in on this amazing
cardboard technology go to team koco.com
slash 360 for a chance to get your very
own free conan headset and remember
conan 360s being made possible thanks to
our friends at AT&T also if you want to
request tickets to one of our live
tapings from comic-con in San Diego
visit team koco.com slash Comic Con and
see us in person live
[Applause]
amazing I don't know I don't know what's
more pathetic me walking around holding
up a box that says Conan or you dismiss
more off that around yeah it's more
pathetic when I do it I'm looking at
Conan
you